laura ingram this is ingram angle from a
very busy washington tonight
how do you solve a problem like kamala
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
all right biden's covered diagnosis as
mild as it may be is still a triggering
event for the dc establishment
what if something happens to the
president and kamala harris has to step
in
well this scenario is a terrifying
prospect for anyone who's followed her
performance over the past few years
now in an administration of punchlines
she's in a class by herself
last sunday during a podcast interview
where she managed to make the democrats
holy grail of abortion sound ever more
callous if that's possible watch you
know listen
women are getting pregnant every day in
america and this is a real issue and we
need to act with a sense of haste
about what is at play what is at stake
uh there's a baby at play just to
clarify now at least she didn't do the
trademark hyena cackle at the end of
that but
she was saying
saving all that for today in
indianapolis where she was nervously
avoiding any opportunity for q a with
the press
so in terms of the format we'll let the
press in
um representative will say a few words
introduce me i'll say a few words and
then we will bid the press goodbye
and we will get into the nitty-gritty of
it all
why is that funny
uh what wasn't funny was her infamous
exchange with the press in poland last
march
she was sent there to eastern europe i i
assumed to reassure our allies over
ukraine but the only one reassured by
her performance was vladimir putin
is the united states willing to make a
specific allocation for ukrainian
refugees
a friend in need is a friend
[Laughter]
this is just another in a long line of
cringe-worthy utterances from our vp
even when
they use paid child actors to push some
nasa initiative the kids couldn't help
save her bad acting
i just love the idea of exploring the
unknown
and then there's other things that we
just haven't figured out or discovered
yet to think about so much that's out
there that we still have to learn
like i love that you're gonna literally
see the craters on the moon with your
own eyes
with your own eyes i'm telling you it is
going to be
unbelievable
those kids should have been paid double
for not laughing there they obviously
couldn't risk just putting her with
regular kids in an informal setting
because lord knows what she'd say this
is how she defended teaching
kindergartners about sex and gender
identity in public schools
we're going to stand up against a law
that says don't say gay
basically
restricting kindergarten through third
grade teachers in florida to be able to
love openly
and teach what they believe is important
for people to understand
well that teachers should be able to
love openly
and to think that i thought reading
spelling arithmetic
that was what five six and seven year
olds were supposed to be learning i'm
totally out of it now for the democrats
having a woman as utterly incompetent as
harris as vice president
is fraught with political peril and of
course for the country it's a national
security nightmare
now if harris has to take over as
commander-in-chief
marinate in that for a moment china is
going to take taiwan in about 30 minutes
now the most important security issue
facing america on the home front of
course is our open border
and the white house put her in charge of
it
and in june 2021 a friendly reporter
asked her a simple question about the
issue
do you have any plans to visit the
border
i'm here in guatemala today at some
point you know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole this whole this
whole thing about the border we've been
to the border we've been to the border
you haven't been to the border
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't
if any one answer effectively ended her
political career i would say that should
be it
thus they work hard to limit her to
carefully choreographed events
every american no matter their income
should be able to afford high-speed
internet right now the cost of internet
is fully covered for millions of
americans call
877-384-2575 or if you have access go to
getinternet.gov
come on that's this isn't fair this
whole monologue is not fair she got the
number right okay
but joe would have struggled with that
there there are though i should say a
few lonely fans of harris out there
historian jeffrey frank in a new york
times column contends that more people
would appreciate her many talents
if only the white house gave her more to
do
there's little evidence that the biden
white house feels much of the urgency
felt by general eisenhower to enhance
the role and preparedness of the person
who might inherit the presidency at any
moment
a historian wrote that comparing kamala
to richard nixon yeah just like just
like eiken nixon if nixon was actually
known to sound like a total bubblehead
kamala's lips move
and words come out
and she manages to say absolutely
nothing
when we discuss this issue and when we
contemplate what it means understand
that it could have a profound
impact
on just about everyone in our country
who has any association
or interest or concern
about these various
issues you see what i mean now the white
house they're not shrinking calmly's
portfolio because they don't like her
personally they are doing it because
she's terrible she's relegated to safe
appearances or interviews with those
groundbreaking journalists at glamour
the skim and something called refinery29
that was on her portfolio today so also
ask yourself this if democrat insiders
thought vice president harris was the
future of the party
why would she be burning staff at the
current rate she's burning it
on social media they call this the
kexodus here's the list and counting now
these aren't minor figures
these people are her senior staff
now national review put it plainly if
you're a kamala harris fan who feels
like she's being snubbed ignored shunted
aside or underutilized it's not the gop
or fox news
this is all on biden or at least biden's
senior staff
look they don't like her they don't
respect her
they know she's a drag and an already
dragged down president
now of course we all know why biden
selected her in the first place though
and i commit that i will in fact appoint
a pick a woman to be vice president
there are a number of women who are
qualified to be president tomorrow i
would pick a woman to be my vice
president
it was more important for biden to
achieve a first the first female woman
of color as vice president than to
actually pick someone for his or her
experience and intellect
now the democrats in the country are in
a serious bind
so how do you solve a problem like
kamala well there's no easy answer
but i can assure you that the senior
democrats in this town are spending a
lot of time racking their brains about
what to do
they ask for biden himself
having kamala a heartbeat away from the
presidency may actually have been an
ingenious move
governor desantis has a theory
i thought biden picking her at first was
like the worst decision ever because
she's not great but she's like the best
impeachment insurance and 25th amendment
insurance anyone could have because as
bad as biden is even though he can
barely read the teleprompter and as much
as people disapprove of them nobody
wants harris
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else